jetzt bin ich dran und nicht darin das
thema präsentieren was mich heute sehr
aufgeregt hat bezüglich beziehungsweise
eher nachdenklich gestimmt hat also
heute bin ich eher die fragen die hier
an den tisch kommt und formal mit
diskutant gleich wissen will wie man das
vielleicht besser lösen könnte denn es
wird ja jetzt 3g am arbeitsplatz geben
mich macht das etwas fassungslos war ich
das gefühl habe schon wieder wird auf
die unternehmer etwas abgedreht als wird
wieder was auf die unternehmer geschoben
ist die jetzt sollen sie jetzt rum gehen
und sagen und haben sie den test dabei
haben sie ihren impfausweis dabei sind
sie genesen ich finde dass es wieder
schira wahnsinn vor einem jahr wohl noch
niemand in der gesellschaft geimpft war
gab es keine regularien arbeitsplatz zu
geben und jetzt plötzlich muss man
getestet genesen oder geimpft sein
sollte man dann immer seinen pass mit
haben immer seine fünfte arbeitsplatz
kann natürlich auch einmal festgelegt
werden ich finde den unternehmer wird
wieder viel zu viel aufgelastet vor
allem habe ich das ganz große gefühl das
mich schon seit langem beschleicht das
auch das zu einer spaltung führen kann
in unternehmen wenn plötzlich immer
gezeigt wird genesen geben schüler
getestet kann man das ja auch irgendwann
mal märkten wer geimpft ist wenn nicht
geimpft ist es wird wieder mehr im
status gerät und das führt dann
schließlich zu einer spaltung in den
unternehmen dasselbe ist der staat will
jetzt wieder das home-office gemacht
wird auch das für dich ist für ein
unternehmer nicht immer einfach home
office ist nicht immer produktiv home
office ist nicht der heilige gral die
wirtschaft braucht die wirtschaft
braucht auch mitarbeiter vor ort und
deswegen versuche ich heute den rat
gemein mit diskutanten was man
eigentlich bessere sind gerade in der
pandemie machen könnte als er ist die
unternehmer 3g durchsetzen müssen ist
natürlich ein spannendes thema vor allen
dingen ein organisatorisches ich habe
mal mein bundestags ausweis mitgebracht
hat eine dauer akkreditierung und
deutschen bundestag und da gibt es
hinten drauf ich weiß nicht ob die
kamera das sehen kann gibt es einen
aufkleber für diejenigen die doppelt
geimpft sind und das haben auch die
bundestagsabgeordneten bundesrat mit
bundesadler und hologrammen natürlich
fälschungssicher in deutschland wird so
was nicht dem zufall überlassen gut
vorbereitet und man muss auch an wein
stehen damit man es bekommt aber man
kann man reingehen und
ausweisen ohne lange seine dokumente
zeigen zu müssen dass man geimpft ist
das kann ich mir gut vorstellen bei
größeren unternehmen schwieriger ist es
organisatorisch bei kleineren
unternehmen der klempner von nebenan er
fragt jetzt nicht sein sein mit klempner
opfer gestern gefeiert hat und jetzt
erstmal im test machen will also ich bin
ein bisschen skeptisch ob sich das in
der breite wirklich kontrollieren lässt
wir werden auch da zu einem zweig
gekommen bin ich von überzeugen
arbeitsplatz also das wird so kommen
weil du kannst ja gar nicht mehr
nachvollziehen die sind es doch nicht
verrückt diese test um das du dass du ja
der rest muss dann im home office
arbeiten wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen schwer bei denen den
handwerks job machen und da entsprechend
auch auf der baustelle oder sonst vor
sein müssen beim kunden aber du kannst
das ja gar nicht mehr kontrollieren in
echtzeit und solange diese gefahr nicht
gebannt ist wird es solche regelungen
geben müssen das heißt wir werden auch
in der wirtschaft solche regelung haben
und dann leicht mit solchen schicken
ausreißen bereit schuler sie hat dann
auch eben die den impf nachweis
kontrollieren müssen aber eigentlich
habe ich nie verstanden weil was ist mit
jemandem geimpft ist aber schon seit
drei monaten nicht testen war kein
mensch weiß ob das virus trägt oder
nicht klar es gibt es auch schwankungen
kann alles möglich falsch sein aber dann
wird ja noch mehr verstehen immer zweig
plus machen würde ja also jetzt rein
rein logisch gedacht 2g erschließt sich
mir nicht wenn alle geimpft sind oder
genießen dann ist zwei gehen natürlich
eine möglichkeit weil dann ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit einer ansteckung
eines genesen auch david ja wie lange
bist du wirklich sicher oder mir müsste
eigentlich antikörper test zu machen ja
nachts aber auch vielleicht ist gut dass
wir den punkt auch mal hier diskutieren
weil das ist auch so ein impfgegner
puncto gott die impfung wir sind ja ganz
überrascht dass die impfungen nicht ein
ganzes leben hält nicht jeder weiß ist
bei vielen impfungen tetanus bei verden
ist das so aber wir uns nicht
vergleichen aber es gibt viele impfungen
die einfach auch nur eine begrenzte zeit
über aber gültig sind also insofern ist
das ja auch kein wunder dass ich das mal
auffrischen muss und man kann gott du
sag mal ja auch wieder bizarre einfach
wie unterschiedlich diese verordnung
sind also man kann irgendwie auf
getestete kann man nicht ins café oder
ins restaurant aber man kann an den
arbeitsplatz also das leuchtet doch
einfach niemand deswegen braucht diese
zwei gegeben also ich muss sagen 3g am
arbeitsplatz ich meine ich halte das
auch für ein bisschen
merkwürdig wie man das dann testen will
aber ich konnte mir vorstellen dass man
da nicht auch die arbeitgeber werden
vermutlich einigermaßen pragmatisch
damit umgehen aber ich find's einfach
komisch dass man auch dieses dass man
aus getestete nicht mehr irgendwie ins
restaurant und café gehen kann wenn man
zur arbeit gehen kann gleichzeitig das
sind doch wie das so meine wer denkt
sich diese regeln was ist genau die
logik wir haben ja natürlich dass die
die sich nicht impfen lassen wollen die
sind nicht mehr gut genug um ein
schwimmbad und restaurant zu gehen aber
zum arbeiten und kämpfen noch gut genug
weil die wirtschaft muss ja am laufen
gehalten werden es tut mir leid aber so
hat sehe ich dass man wenn jemand auch
als zur arbeit gehen kann für unsere
wirtschaft arbeitet soll auch ins
schwimmbad gehen können ich verstehe
nicht wie wir da zweige machen können am
arbeitsplatz 3g s ist die weibliche
schönheit mich ein zweig am arbeitsplatz
umsetzen sollte und ich habe auch schon
ein zwei fälle gehört wo das anscheinend
sogar schon umgesetzt wurde dann nehmen
wir menschen die lebensgrundlage diese
natürlich brauchen um zu existieren
arbeit geht es braucht man wie können
wir denn da zweig machen was wir denn
dann passieren sollen bei kompletter
lohnfortzahlungen sind jeden verlassen
wollen zu hause bleiben oder wie stellt
man sich das vor es gibt eine pflicht
der menschen die nicht geimpft sind sich
in einen zustand zu bringen so dass sie
nicht mehr ansteckend sind für andere
und andere nicht mehr gefährden dass
diese ja das reicht ja offenkundig nicht
mehr weil die testphasen so sind dass
ich trotzdem noch ansteckend bin wenn
ich mal getestet bin wer sagt mir wann
bin ich getestet und dergleichen gibt es
sehr große unterschiede auch regionale
unterschiede so deswegen werden wir
dahin kommen zu einem zweig oder sogar
zwei geht plus regelungen wir sehen uns
ja doch im fußball was war das für ein
aufstand als wir hier gesagt haben hier
an dieser stelle mich warum spielt er
eigentlich nur der ist nicht getestet
nicht geimpft und will sie auch nicht
impfen lassen aber spielt in stadien wo
eine zweig oder zweige plus regel geld
und wie ist das über einzubringen jetzt
auf einmal heißt es ja auch ein kimmig
muss wenn er in solchen steinen spielt
sich entsprechend impfen geimpfte auf
den platz laufen so wird es auch mit
anderen verordnung beziehungsweise mit
anderen regeln als
unverständlich wie wärs beckham ich
gemacht werden konnte aber gleichzeitig
gibt so hier seltsam kuriositäten wie
beim fliegen im augenblick das airline
so wie zum beispiel die lufthansa reihe
für reihe aussteigen lassen begründung
ich habe extra nachgefragt weil ich
nicht ganz verstanden habe es könnte ein
aero so liegl entstehen der dann so auf
die noch zinsen den niederfeld oder
ähnliches weil die luft unten april hoch
interessant danach spart man dann aber
die kosten für den aussteiger finger und
quetscht das ganze flugzeug in einen bus
um ihn zum terminal zu bauen das ist
völlig irre ein absolut aber gut man
wundert sich da auch nicht mehr und dann
ist auch in ordnung
benedikt also erstens durch schaue schon
gar nicht ein sie kann sich schon merken
was wo wie waren gilt wie gesagt man hat
irgendwie ein vorteil wenn er geimpftes
und mit mir testen regelmäßig also ist
es ja gar nicht aber eben menschen das
nicht machen
nochmal ich glaube wir stehen auf
österreich zu den maßnahmen weil es
immer verstärkt werden bald zweig haben
zeige plus und dann wären wir merken das
ist alles nichts hilft und dann im
lockeren enden also ich glaub ich muss
keinem einen überblick haben im laub
dann für beide oder nur für die
ungeimpften wahrscheinlich also
schrittweise haben secret oder sachsen
macht das doch jetzt läuft ein
verunglückter so also es gibt keine
ausnahme und österreich hat ja die
locker und für alle ich ja aber eben das
war ja auch zuerst zweig und dann für
ungeimpfte und jetzt ist für alle ab
montag alle und das ist ja übrigens das
nächste ist hieße den ganzen sommer
stichwort versprechen noch mal oder es
wird kein lockte mehr geben und deswegen
findet am schwierigsten das massive
vertrauensverluste stattfindet und dass
wir wieder bei den punkt wie will man
denn heute noch irgendwas überreden aber
überzeugen wenn die dann auch höheren
anna die impfung bringt am ende auch
nicht wirklich was am schluss gibt ein
zweig und ich muss mich testen oder es
kommt egal ob dann warum soll ich mich
überhaupt noch impfen lassen also so
einfach kann man das gar nicht erklären
deswegen wird die impfpflicht darum bin
ich hergekommen ist angekündigt für
februar zur gnade frist lässt sich jetzt
allerdings februar in der hoffnung
vermutlich dass man sich doch nicht
brauchen wird weil sonst würden es dann
zu spät ansetzen